us promised the health minister is with
us now Helen Whiteley hi good morning
thanks very much indeed for joining us
on the program this morning uh let's
start first of all with the NHS
Workforce plan if you wouldn't mind I
know there's lots to talk about
um we are short of 12 000 Hospital
doctors more than 50 000 nurses and
midwives so said Jeremy Hunt when he was
uh chairman of the health select
committee 13 years of conservative
government so two things are happening
first I'll talk about what we've been
doing over the last couple of years at
the moment and then come to the
long-term Workforce plan which we're
going to be publishing later this week
so since 2010 we've increased the number
of doctors in the NHS by over 40 000
nurses in the NHS by over 50 000 we do
have record numbers of Staff in the NHS
in fact in the last election the
government made a commitment in our
Manifesto that we would recruit and
retain over 50 000 more nurses in the
NHS and we're on track to do that but we
know that we need need to go further we
know also that a significant proportion
of our staff are internationally trained
doctors nurses and other Health Care
Professionals they're doing a really
good job I should say it's really
important so we hugely value the
international Workforce as well as our
UK Workforce but we want to be able to
recruit and retain more UK trained
doctors and nurses and that's going to
be part of our long-term Workforce plan
this is a historic first for the
National Health Service actually to have
a long-term future looking Workforce
plan that's going to be published later
this week pay them more
well we have just been going through
here a number of pay negotiations with
national health service staff and
reached agreement with over a million of
those staff which includes for instance
middle nurses or band five nurses that's
usually a nurse working in the ward
getting a pay rise around 5 000 pounds
we draw on the recommendations in our
pay process of course the pay review
well actually I was I've already been
asked about this question this morning
I'm not something that government does
is always looks at at what received from
the pay review bodies I've been involved
in that process myself in the past as a
health minister with oversight of
Workforce and huge evaluation
I'm actually not going to preempt the
next stage in the process but they've
said six to six and a half percent so
I'm not going to preempt the next stage
in the process so what happens is the
pay review bodies provide their
recommendations to government government
reviews that and then responds with a
pay proposal obviously government has to
look overall what is Affordable and the
Prime Minister has been very clear in
fact talked about this over the weekend
about our need to be responsible with
the public finances our number one
priority of course is we must bring down
inflation so government has a look at
things in the round so I'm not going to
preempt the response we'll make to the
patient but just to clarify the peer
review project is take direction from
government budgets don't they so what do
you tell them how much money that's
available so there's the government
provides a input into the pay review and
the Prime Minister church is the
Department of the pay review boards so
they they have a it's a it is an
independent process I said I actually as
a minister and the Prime Minister choose
the chairman of the pay review boards so
I don't know the exact process of the
appointment
so the chairman choose the PM chooses
the chairman of the pay review boards
and then the government tells the peer
review boards what the upper limits are
of the budgets and then they say okay as
a result six percent for uh nurses and
doctors and six and a half percent for
teachers or whatever it might be so you
say okay
so the way the process works is the pair
with your bodies gather evidence to take
inputs from government they also take
evidence from the workforce unions from
the from the health unions they also
look at the kind of rates of pay in The
Wider Market they look at inflation so
they're looking around combat with a
recommendation yeah well actually
there's a number of pay-per-view bodies
different parts of the public sector
some have reported back others haven't
government has to look at public sector
pay and pay in the round and it makes
sense for us to do that because we have
to make responsible decisions as
governments I mean nobody well I I
didn't for a moment say that I mean
let's be clear we take the advice or
recommendations from the pay of your
bodies but you'll understand that
government has to be responsible with
the public of finances that's why I
can't say Here and Now what the outcome
of of the whole process is going to be
we know we have a number one priority of
bringing down inflation and actually the
job in government and job of prime
minister is to make tough decisions
just to clarify can Junior doctors can
Police Service can teachers expect
between six and a half at six and six
and a half percent has been recommended
by the public sector pay review bodies
so I'm not going to preempt the outcome
of the government's response to the pay
review bodies but when your colleagues
and indeed you have sat there previously
and we've talked about percentage pay
increases you've always said we have to
abide by what the independent peer
review bodies suggest to us I don't
believe that is what we've always said
what we always say usually saying
certainly what I've said in the in the
in the past I believe on this is that we
look at the recommendations from the pay
review bodies it's very important that
they provide us with chairman is chosen
by the Prime Minister and you tell them
what the budgets are so what's that
what's the point so the point is to have
a process where you have expert advice
on recommendations on pay but the
government has to make decisions in the
round but what we're also doing as I
said it's coming four is later this week
with a long time term Workforce plan
because on the one hand here and now
when we are supporting talk to me about
the lung cancer Investments sorry the
lung cancer Investments I'm delighted to
talk to you about the announcement we're
making today which is a rolling out of a
national lung cancer screening program
so that is going to be inviting people
who are at higher risk of lung cancer
for instance that people who have been
smoking age between 55 and 74 to come
forward to be assessed and then invited
to non-cancer screening tests the reason
we're doing that is because very sadly
lung cancer is one of the country's
biggest Killers it kills over 35
000 people a year and that is partly
because too often lung cancer is
diagnosed late the majority of people
are diagnosed late with lung cancer and
he will diagnosed late treatment is less
likely to be effective in fact
unfortunately If you're diagnosed late
with lung cancer your prospects of
surviving five years are only around
four percent If you're diagnosed early
it's more like 60 percent Prospect of
surviving lung cancer and we know that
with this kind of targeted screening
program we can then diagnose the
majority of lung cancers early and that
makes a big difference to people's
outcomes one of the other big concerns
of course is breast cancer we've seen
The Duchess of York is recovering
thankfully really she's had a mastectomy
talking openly about it a lady that came
to talk to us Susan Michaelis she has
lobular breast cancer which is a perhaps
a breast cancer that is not as well
known as the more normal kinds if you
will and she came to see you after she'd
been on our program you very kindly
agreed to see her and you said that you
would bring up a lobular breast cancer
with the Institute of cancer research
have you done that
um well I've had several uh meetings
with cancer Charities and cancer
organizations and that one of many
things that we talk about
um I'll have to get back to you about
these specific details of all the
conversations I've had with breast
cancer Charities
um but one of the things that I've been
talking to breast cancer Charities is
about our screening programs we know
that screening is really really
important in fact as The Duchess of York
has been talking about and I wish her
very well from her recovery from her
treatment and and she's emphasized
rightly the importance of people taking
up their invitation to go for screening
and we continue to look at what things
we can do to make sure that we diagnose
cancer as early as possible so people
have the best possible outcome we wish
you well most certainly all of us
watching this morning as well I'm sure
final thought the Prime Minister
yesterday telling people that they
should hold their nerve over their
mortgage payments uh going up you're
looking forward to saying that on the
doorstep when you're campaigning to the
next election I think it's been slightly
misquoted on on that but I think over
rule his point is that we as a country
you know we have to we know that it's
going to take time for us to bring
inflation down it's his number one
priority clearly it's one of the five
priorities that he's set out was to harm
along with growing the economy reducing
our debt cutting our waiting lists and
stopping the boats you'll have heard and
holding our five priorities that we have
to do but inflation is not going to come
down overnight this is hard work that we
have to do as a country that includes a
government making responsible tough
decisions on the nation's finances okay
for now thanks very much indeed thank
you